hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round nine of
defeated candidates tournament 2022.
it's dingler and versus young shisht of
dudum uh we've shown all of the games
that were played yesterday and this is
the final one but i think it definitely
deserves to be shown because it's
basically the perfect game uh except
that in order for it to be a draw one of
the players had to find an engine a
precise defense but the problem is that
the solution required happened exactly
on move 40. so this move had to be made
in order to reach time control to be
awarded additional time and for the game
to continue uh the one of the players
who was unable to do this and that
result uh resulted in a winning position
for the other one so not spoiled too
much you will really enjoy it as it's uh
it's such an ugly
move to find uh i don't think we've ever
shown a move this ugly but it's also
beautiful in in a sense so let's dive
straight into it ding has the white
pieces and uh as in all the other games
he opens with c4 he goes for the english
opening knight to f6 we have g3 uh we
have e6 and now bishop to g2 do the
strikes in the center with d5 knight to
f3 ended now d captures um
on c4 so this is the so-called neo
catalan defense uh queen to a4 with
check going after the pawn now knight
beat the d7 and the ding grabs the pawn
back we have a6 and queen to c2 so this
has all been played many many times
nothing new here pawn to c5 and now uh
we have knight to c3 queen to c7 just
continuing development castles and now
pawn to b6 preparing the fiance to the
light square bishop to counter ding's
light square bishop and you don't really
have any good discoveries uh so uh
you know let's just continue development
pawn to d4 uh we have bishop to b7 and
now d captures on c5 the a much more
common move here is the bishop to f4
even though the position has not been
reached so many times uh still bishop to
f4 there are some 10 games in the
database d captures on c5 incredibly
rare it's been played only two times
once by levon aronian and once by evan
charic uh so bishop captures on c5 and
the bishop to f4 now attacking the black
queen bishop to d6 and here we have a
trade captures captures in the rook
after d1 attacking dude as queen
and here we have queen to c7 in the game
versus pelletier uh queen the e7 was
played but here we have queen to c7 and
we go into the game that lavon arnhem
played against
in the tata steel tournament
of 2015 that ended in a draw uh and in
the game ariana played rook 8 to c1
which makes sense your uh this rook
already occupies the default you want to
put this rook on the on the open c file
but ding has a different idea he plays
uh
rook to d4 which is uh pretty incredible
because uh not uh uh our ariana's move
is not in any of the moves recommended
by the engine uh but the things rook to
d4 is but only if you let the engine
really crunch the numbers so ding really
prepared this rook to d4 move and you
can be sure that uh he knows this
position very well and it is now as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game so instead of having a rook on the
dnc files ding now wants to play rook a
to d1 and double up rooks and the d file
and this rook 8 to c8 is most likely
coming you're also going to play queen
d2 and have this uh
triple
uh battery on the d file so here we have
castles
and rook 8 to d1 we have rook 8 the c8
by duda and now queen to d2 getting the
queen away from the the c file
knight to c5 now and here duda is asking
okay it's it's a very nice idea but what
what does it actually do is there
something is there some way that you can
look for some advantage here uh and of
course i know you guys are wondering is
b4 the move here
no it's not it's one of the rare cases
where it's not the ding actually plays
queen to f4 and this is what we discuss
in a lot of games that we show
in these uh top grand master games where
they you know everyone is perfectly
prepared there there's no basically no
good way to surprise your opponent uh
the only way you can do it is with a
move like this to create some sort of an
imbalance in the position and look for
winning chances there even though the
with perfect play of course everything
is a draw uh but okay queen captures on
f4 now dude accepts this uh now he will
mess up the being spawn structure
captures captures and knight seat e4
offering more trades we have knight
captures bishop captures and now knight
to e5 ding now offers a trade of bishops
and the duda declines or rather he
invited him to capture on d5 he he
attacks the a2 pawn being defends it he
pushes it all the way to a4 and now pawn
to a5 we have pawn to e for now chasing
away the bishop and bishop to b3
attacking ding's rook we have rook 1 to
d3 and now rook to c1 would check nicely
uh activating that that rook improving
the
the pieces uh bishop to f1 and now
bishop to c2 attacking the rook here so
rook d3 and now uh duda just plays rook
to d1 uh attacks the rook on d4 and
offers a trade on d1 so rook captures
bishop captures and now rook to c4 just
nicely defending everything on the
fourth rank and also maybe trying to
make it a bit uncomfortable for this
bishop on d1 so here rook to d8 by duda
and now knight to c6 attacking the rook
and you have to be very careful here if
you go some like rooks rook to ca then
we just deliver a check and pick up the
rook so yeah you have to be careful duda
plays the absolute best move he plays
rook to d2 he even allows ding to grab
the back rank uh because this also comes
with a
pawn sacrifice now that the back rank
has been vacated knight captures an a5
biting and now of course the knight
cannot be captured because of a
checkmate on the back rank you have to
give up some pieces here and then you
know the ding just gobbles them up and
delivers checkmate so g6 by duda and now
rook the c8 delivering a check king to
g7 and now knight to c4 attacking the
rook and the b6 spawn and this is what
duda prepared and why he gave up that
pawn it's actually not a problem rook to
c2 attacks the knight here and now we're
not going to capture on b6 if we capture
on b6 just recaptures on b2 and of
course both ding and the
duda knows
know that this uh
can be held to a draw so b4 advancing
the pawn now preparing a5 and now comes
rook to c1 this is what
duda prepared and now it seems like dink
can just win a pawn here and he's gonna
have to connect it past spawns but not
really but before i show you what uh
happened in the game we actually have a
nice photo of this moment so here it is
um
let's uh check it out for you oops uh
not that one i always forget to prepare
the uh the new one that i prepare uh
yeah there you go all right so that's
the photo so you can see uh this is the
position uh everything is uh you know
you know set duda put his rook on c1 and
it's now ding to make a move uh but uh
you know there's not much to the
position the position is uh fairly equal
so let's just enjoy it for a few seconds
as i know you guys really enjoy photos
and now see what duda prepared so rook
to c1 and ding goes for a knight
captures on b6 and now rook to b1 this
is the idea the b pawn uh will now
disappear the problem is if you advance
it let's say pawn to b5 uh bishop e2 and
now you can resign that's it game over
so after rook to b1 king the g2 by ding
and now duda just gobbles up the b4 pawn
so rook captures on b4 and now we have
pawn to a5 ding starts um
advancing his past pawn rook to b3 you
want to prepare rook to a3 the a4 square
is covered by the knight and now rook to
c1 putting pressure on the bishop so
bishop f3 with check king the g1 and the
rook a3 not in a rush to go after the
pawn here
knight to c4 by ding and rook to a2 and
here comes the the the
beautiful moment knight to e5 biting
putting pressure on the bishop here and
this is uh the the position from the
thumbnail or rather i believe i'm gonna
put this position on the thumbnail uh
what can you do here it's a winning
position for ding unless duda plays such
a
disgustingly you know spectacular engine
line that saves the game
but i don't want to spoil it too much
for you you know feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only move that
saves the game for do that while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the knight on e5 uh attacks the f7 pawn
and rook the c7 is the actual threat and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show the move is bishop to h5 that's
the that's the good stuff with this move
as disgusting as it is uh we are
indirectly defending the the f7 pawn and
now the point is after rook to c7 we
just played g5 that's how we defend the
pawn and after f captures and g5 we play
ninth captures on e4 and now a6 i hope
you did not forget about our good friend
the bishop on f1 guarding that a6 pawn
knight captures on g5 and now king the
g2
we have king to f6 and now knight to d7
with check king e7 knight to b6 with
check from the rook king to d6 and now
rook to c1 uh we cut off the black king
from uh from reaching the uh the c file
and also from advancing all the way to
the past pawn but now bishop to f3 check
now this bishop comes back and guards
the queening square king g3 bishop goes
back to c6 and white will not be winning
this uh
this game so the rook and the bishop
guard the a8 square and there's no way
for white to push this for a win white
can still be uh annoying and try to push
but white will not be winning this game
so that's what was needed in order to to
survive this this ugly looking bishop to
h5 but i mean good luck seeing this on
mov40 you know you have to make a move
to reach time control so do that played
bishop captures an e4 which also looks
very nice to win a pawn the problem is
now the position is winning for ding but
only if ding plays it perfectly so rook
to c7 goes after the f7 pawn now comes
knight to d5 attacks the rook rook
captures an f7 with check came to g8 and
now pawn to a6 now ding starts pushing
that pass pawn
knight to b4 and now rook to a7 you you
you you would expect a7 here but this is
a problem after knight to c6 so yeah
it's not not very clean so rook to a7 is
much better yeah still keeping the king
on the back rank and also we can play
rook to a8 check at some point if the
bishop ever moves from from this
diagonal but we are just nicely
defending the a6 pawn until we improve
our position sufficiently so here knight
to c6 attacking the rook and rook the c7
ding avoids the trade and it is the in
fact the best move to play knight to d4
and now pawn to f3 even offering a pawn
to get some material of the board
because ding's position is overwhelming
knight captures an f3 but anything uh
you know nothing else it works better
either so knight captures on f3 knight
captures bishop captures and pawn the a7
but still how are you uh reaching that
a8 square the bishop ended the rook
regarding it well uh as usual we're
gonna have to use the strongest piece
that exists in any end game and that of
course is the king so here we have
bishop d5 by duda and now pawn to h4
first getting rid of the target on h2
rook to a4 going after the f4 pawn and
now bishop to b5 defending with a tactic
of course now if you capture on f4 uh we
just play bishop c6 and that's it
there's no stopping the the pawn from
queening if captures captures rook a4 we
deliver a check and now we have the back
ring covered so there's that so after
rook to b5 rook to a5 attacking the
bishop but now rook to d7 again
ding is very very resourceful here of
course you you cannot capture the bishop
if you capture we just captured this one
and then queen the pawn so here duda has
to go back rook to a2 and now the king
enters the game king to f1 now of course
the king is coming all the way to b1
we're gonna take some valuable squares
away from this rock because you can't
just leave it there otherwise we're
gonna capture the bishop and then
capture the rook and you will uh
slowly but surely win more squares so
bishop g2 checking you won't do that can
just repeat moves and uh you know wait
to see will this actually happen king d1
king h8 king the c1 and now bishop to e4
duda doesn't allow dink to
come any closer but now rook to c7
uh do that to make the move rook to a5
and now we have bishop to d7 going after
the pawn here rook to a1 with check king
to b2 and now even rook to b1 with check
but now we gain access to the a2 square
so rook to b6
going back to help out with the defense
and now king the a3 here ding could
easily blunder the game rather not
blunder but allow do that um maybe
get a draw if he rushes bishop to c6
that's why the rook is on b6 to prevent
this because now uh you're just going to
play rook to a6 with check that's how
you do it and after king b3 we're going
to capture here and now you lose the
pawn rook captures rook captures on a7
and you no longer have winning chances
but after king a3 now ding shows that he
his king is coming to a5 and that's it
uh so king to g8 we have king to a4 and
he was in this position on move 61 that
young sister duda resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
now one uh once you make a move because
there's not all that much to make now
bishop to c6 can be played and there's
nothing for you to do if you capture on
c6 we're just going to capture with the
rook and after rook captures we now
bring a queen into game even with checks
so of course that's completely winning
and uh if you don't do this if let's say
after bishop the c6 you go for rook to
a6 now our king is uh you know uh deep
in deep enough in the position and can
play king to b5 and now the rook is
hanging so there's no way to actually uh
you know defend against this if you play
bishop captures we just captured the
rook if you capture with the rook it's
not a problem just a8 queen and this is
now checkmate so beautiful beautiful
stuff
uh so yeah after king day four do the
resigns and the ding gets his first
victory in the tournament which means
that you know yesterday we said that uh
half of the candidates still have yet to
score their first victory but now
everyone scored their first victory
except for duda so duda still needs to
get a win these are the standings after
round nine of the defeated candidates
tournament so let's check it out yeah
nippon she is still leading the
tournament six and a half points that's
four wins uh and five draws zero losses
so janiponishi so far the only player
without a loss fabiano karwana five and
a half points uh hikaru nakamura and
dingler and tied with four and a half
points rajab of firuja and uh rapport
tied with four points and in last place
now young shisht of duda who like i said
has yet to score his first win in
defeated candidates tournament so really
good stuff we'll see uh what happens now
it's uh basically all up all up to
nippon issue will he win the candidates
tournament because he already faced
fabiana twice and fabiano will not be
able to grab points away from from nepo
so it's uh you know definitely up to him
if he can continue playing
with this strength
until the end then we definitely have a
winner but it's still it's still way too
early to tell so yeah that's the game
we've covered uh all the four games of
round nine so i hope you guys enjoyed
that as i believe there was quite a lot
to enjoy and especially this move i mean
it's been a while since we've had such a
move i mean bishop to h5 wow that's
bishop to h5 so what a move
uh so yeah once again hope you enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank ultimate
poker coaching muhammad al-saban michael
bauer's nakarowa den and matthew benoit
chess is hard for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens uh in the chess
world uh so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day